si les allemands sont reçus au château
de versailles pour une première
présentation du traité le 7 mai 1919
pour les autrichiens cette même scène a
lieu au château de saint germain en laye
le 2 juin il y à toute une haie
d'honneur des dragons des militaires
français
il y à tous les diplomates les
journalistes etc qui attendent mais les
deep les grands diplomates sont déjà
dans la pièce à vouvant que les délégués
rentrer dans la petite porte même chemin
le 10 septembre pour la signature du
traité
les autrichiens passe par la petite
porte je rappelle un 17 délégations
passe par la cour d'honneur ce sont les
vainqueurs
le vaincu l'autrichien avec ses délégués
une dizaine de personnes le 2 juin 1919
et le 10 septembre 1910 passe par ici
parce que c'est une délégation de 20 que
tout se déroule dans cette salle numéro
une nous contrairement aux allemands les
autrichiens décide d'adopter une
attitude positive dans l'espoir de
pouvoir négocier le traité la méthode ne
sera pas aussi probante puisque la
méthode dure ne marche pas
la méthode sympathique à l'autrichienne
ne marche pas non plus le traité
quasiment fait quand on leur donne ce
document de jeu au final 380 articles
signés le 10 septembre à contrecoeur
pour les autrichiens qui perds ton
territoire et se retrouve des tâches et
de l'allemagne l'autriche allemande est
interdite les alliés souhaitent une
république d'autriche
ce traité on l'a même oublié en france
dans l'entre-deux-guerres
c'est lorsqu'il ya en 1938 l'anchois
j'ai cherché dans la presse si on disait
qu'il ya bien un traité de saint germain
en laye c'est quand même minimum et bien
la presse locale petit réveil ne parle
même plus on est moins de 20 ans après
du traité de saint germain en laye comme
si on avait mauvaise conscience d'avoir
ce traité ne l'avoir pas respecté de ne
pas avoir les moyens de le faire
respecter
face au grand reich l'attitude cordiale
autrichienne n'aura pas suffi à la
négociation mais elle entraînera une
attitude cordiale de la part de georges
clemenceau et ses alliés un honneur on
peut
pour les autrichiens les autrichiens les
délégués autriche a mené par karl rahner
repasseront par cet escalier d'honneur
au même moment en hongrie la dictature
bolchévique empêche les délégués ont
droit de se rendre à saint germain en
laye leur traité de paix aura lieu un an
plus tard au grand trianon à versailles
le 4 juin 1920
c'est sûrement l'un des traités qui a
été le plus durement ressenti
parce que la hongrie a perdu plus de la
moitié de son territoire donc ça a été
une perte territoriale absolument énorme
à laquelle d'ailleurs je pense des
hongrois ne s'attendait pas elle perd
des terres le territoire profit la
tchécoslovaquie au profit de la roumanie
c'est la transylvanie qui est un énorme
territoire et au profit aussi du royaume
des serbes des croates et des slovènes
qui deviendra la yougoslavie une année
est passée mais les hongrois tente la
même stratégie de négociation que les
autrichiens le démembrement de cet
empire d'autriche hongrie a abouti à la
création de nouveaux états qui ont pris
du coup part du côté des alliés
et puis il nous restait finalement que
deux états qui ont toujours été
considérés comme des ennemis l'autriche
réduite à sa partie germanophone
et puis la hongrie réduite au coeur de
la partie magyar de cet ancien pays et
donc l'autriche et la hongrie se sont
retrouvés du côté des ennemis alors que
eux clamait le fait qu'ils avaient été
pris dans un enfer beaucoup plus vaste
qui n'était pas responsable de des actes
de cet ancien empire
aujourd'hui il en reste deux nouveaux
états de nouvelles la nation au coeur de
l'europe et avec une une amertume
certaine de la part du peuple hongrois
face ce démembrement de de son
territoire
une amertume pour cet ancien empire
austro hongrois qui aura sa part de
responsabilité dans le déclenchement de
la seconde guerre mondiale